بين العزاء السلام عليكم رجح ناخبون
ومراقبون في مصر ان تكون مستويات المشاركه
في جوله الاعاده لانتخابات الرئاسه
المصريه اقل من مثيلاتها في الجوله الاولى
للانتخابات
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما هي العوامل التي حكمت مستوى
المشاركه الشعبيه في الجوله الثانيه من
انتخابات الرئاسه المصريه والى اي حد يمكن
ان تنعكس نسبه المشاركه في الانتخابات على
موقف الرئيس المقبل في مواجهه التحديات
على كثره الموضوعات التي يمكن ان يختلف
حولها المصريون هذه الايام يتفق الجميع
على ان المهام والتحديات التي تواجه رئيس
مصر المقبل من الجسامه والخطوره بمكان وفي
ظل الظروف ال بالغه التعقيد من الناحيتين
السياسيه والدستوريه التي تمر بها البلاد
الان تزداد اهميه عنصر المشاركه في
الانتخابات التي ستحدد هويه الرئيس
باعتبارها سلاحا مهما في يد رجل مصر الاول
الذي لا يعرف حتى الان ما امه او صلاحياته
اول الواصلين الى المركز المهمه تختلف
طبعا عن مهمه من سياتي بعده
زياده على الغموض الذي يلف نتيجه الجوله
التي يواجه فيها المصريون اختيارا صعبا
بين مرشح الاخوان المسلمين محمد مرسي و
اخر رئيس وزراء في عهد الرئيس السابق حسني
مبارك الفريق احمد شفيق تظل نسبه المشاركه
هاجسا اخر لا يقل اهميه عن بقيه الهواجس
التي تعتمل في قلوب المصريين اختارت على
التغيير عايزين نغير بعد والثاني النظام
القديم يعني فكرنا بمبارك ثلاثين سنه في
الفساد عايزين نغير
النقطه الفيصل اللي اكثر
الاخوان
ناخبون وعاملون في مراكز الاقتراع قالوا
ان نسبه الاقبال على التصويت تراجعت بدرجه
ملحوظه عن مثيلتها في الدوره الاولى
لاسيما في اليوم الثاني ملاحظه ارجعها
بعضهم الى ارتفاع درجه الحراره والرطوبه
بينما راى اخرون ان المساله اكبر من ان
يلقي بها على عوامل الطبيعه بل على طبيعه
من يتحكم في سير الامور في مصر ما بعد
الثوره وبين هذا وذاك فئه ثالثه رجحت
تاثير دعوات المقاطعه انطلاقا من ان
التعايش مع الاوضاع لا يعني الاختيار بين
مرشحين لا يعبران عن الثوره كما يقولون
بالنسبه لهؤلاء فان فوز شفيق سيضمن للنظام
السابق بقائه في اعلى مواقع السلطه
التنفيذيه اما فوز بورس فهو وفق رؤيتهم
مدخل لمكروه اخر هو اقامه دوله دينيه
ستكون نتائجها كارثيه على المستوى الداخلي
خارجي من وجهه نظري وفي سياق محاوله تفسير
سلوك الناخبين في جوله الاعاده تريد ايضا
حاله الغموض الدستوري والسياسي بعد حل
مجلس الشعب وقبل اكتمال الدستور وهو ما
يجعل من رئاسه مصر في المرحله المقبله
منصبا غير واضح الصلاحيات والتاثير وهو ما
قد يحد من رغبه البعض في المشاركه في
اختياره عمليات فرز صناديق الاقتراع رئيسا
جديدا لمصر رئيس ينصب في خضم هائلين من
المشاكل والتحديات التي قد يسهم ضعف
المشاركه الشعبيه في اختياره في تقليل
قدرته على مواجهتها
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في مكتبنا هنا
في القاهره الدكتور عمار على حسن الكاتب
والباحث السياسي الدكتور عبد الخالق فاروق
مدير مركز النيل للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
ومعنا كذلك في استوديوهاتنا في القاهره
الدكتور مجدى عبد الحميد رئيس الجمعيه
المصريه للنهوض بالمشاركه الاجتماعيه
مرحبا بكم جميعا دكتور عمار سبقت
الانتخابات الرئاسيه جوله الحسم في
الاعاده تطورات بالغه الدقه والاهميه في
الساحه السياسيه المصريه من قبيل منح رجال
المخابرات والجيش حق الضبطيه القضائيه من
قبيل حل اه اه او الحكم الصادر عن المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا بابقاء الفريق احمد شفيق
في السباق الرئاسي و اه اه اه قرار بطلان
الانتخابات التي على اساسها يتم انتخاب
مجلس الشعب بما يؤدي الى حل البرلمان في
نهايه المطاف اه اه اه اه حل البرلمان
واسترداد السلطه التشريعيه من قبل المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه وبحث اصدار اعلان
دستوري مكمل خلال ساعات يمنح المجلس
القوات المسلحه حق التشكيله التاسيسيه
للدستور كل هذه التطور ال برايك هل اثرت
في الناخب المصري ايجابا ام سلبا في
الانتخابات لا لا شك انها اثرت سلبا بدليل
نسبه الاقبال الضعيفه حتى هذه اللحظه
مقارنه
بالجوله الاولى مقارنه بالانتخابات
التشريعيه حاله الفرح التي كانت حاضره في
كل الطوابير الطويله اثناء عمليه
الاستفتاء رغم ان يكون بدايه الكارثه
والخروج عن المسار الحقيقي الا ان هناك
كان هناك تفاؤل وامل مفرط في ان هذا
المسار المؤسسه الذي يتم عبر انتخابات
متابعه من الممكن يشكل يشكل مؤسسات الدوله
التي تمثل الاركان نظام بنيه بعد ثوره 25
يناير التي نادي صورها باسقاط النظام
وبناء نظام جديد على القاضيه الان حتى هذه
المؤسسات يتم اه التخلص منها يعني انا
البرلمان وبعد ان اكثر من مليار جنيه
بالقوه المصريين يتم
المصاريف الرسميه ولكن فيما يتعلق بال بال
ناخبين او المرشحين اقصد طبعا اه حدث ولا
حرج في النهايه كل المؤسسات التي تبنى
مفخخه بما في ذلك حتى منصب رئيس الجمهوريه
رئيس ياتي لا يعرف صلاحياته هذه الصلاحيات
ممكن ان تقيد
بالجمعيه التاسيسيه للدستور التي ستضع له
صلاحيات وتقيد بحكم الواقع ان هذا الرئيس
لا يستطيع ان يدير دولاب العمل في الدوله
المصريه دون ان يتعاون معه المجلس العسكري
دون ان تتعاون معه اجهزه الامن اجهزه
الحكم المحلي البيروقراطيه المصريه الدوله
العميقه اللي بيسميه الدكتور عبد الخليل
الدوله السفلى هذه الدوله والدوله السفليه
هي التي تتحكم في مقاليد وفي مفصل الامور
وتحتاج في حقيقه الامر الى تفكيك وتتابع
ولكن بشرط ان القوى الثوريه او تتمكن من
ان تصل الى بعض مؤسسات الدوله في حقيقه
الامر اما اذا غيبت هذه الدوله من الممكن
ان تتوحد انت سيد زكي ان تتجنب بعض
المزالق والاخطاء التي وقعت فيها في
الفتره المقبله لكن احنا نراهن على ان
الثقافه السياسيه للمصريين قد تغيرت وان
هناك حاله رغبه لدى قطاعات عريضه الكتل
الحركه الكتله الثوريه الحركه في اكمال
الثوره رغم كل ال ال العقبات والعثرات
التي توضع في طريقها بما في ذلك اه اه اه
انتخابات رئاسه الجمهوريه دكتور عبد
الخالق هل هل من العوامل الاخرى في رايك
حكمت المستويات المشاركه في الجوله
الثانيه التي تبدو ادنى بكثير من سابقتها
بل ال المؤشر يتفرج من اه الاستفتاء في
باريس 2011 ثم الانتخابات البرلمانيه اذن
قليلا من الاستفتاء ثم الجوله الاولى من
انتخابات الرئاسه ابني اكثر ثم هذه الجوله
التي على ما يبدو لن تتجاوز خمسه وثلاثين
في الاجزاء حاولنا ان في كلمه واحده هذا
الجو العام ل اه عمليه الاداره العمليه
الانتخابيه الجاريه الان نستطيع ان اصفها
في كلمه واحده هي الخوف كل المشاركين في
هذه العمليه سواء كان المناخ بين سواء كان
المرشحين للرئاسه سواء كانت الاجهزه
المحيطه بالعمليه والتي تديرها بصوره او
باخرى بشكل يشوف لي اه اه يحكمهم عنصر
الخوف والفزع الذين سيصوتون للفريق احمد
شفيق يصوتون من باب الخوف والفزع من قوه
الاخوان المسلمين ومن اداء الاخوان
المسلمين في الفتره الاخيره الذين سيذهبون
للتصويت لصالح الدكتور محمد موسوي للاخوان
المسلمين يصوتون خوفا من اعاده انتاج
النظام القديم بكل النظام القديم العنصر
الاساسي في الموضوع السيكولوجيه التي تحكم
حركه ملايين المصريين الان في التدافع من
اجل اختيار هذا الرئيس او ذاك هذا الشخص
او ذاك هي عنصر الخوف ده واحد اثنين انه
ايضا يعني فقط انا يعني اود ان
اسالك خمسه ملايين اعطوا اصواتهم مرسي
خمسه وثمانين اخرين اعطوا اصواتهم شفيق
طبعا في ظل وجود بدايه الواقع يعني هؤلاء
بالطبع لا يختلف تصويتهم تقريبا عندما
اتحدث عن خوف اتحدث عن حتى من الناحيه
الاختياريه عندما يذهب اه اه اه اه ناخذ
للادلاء مصالح الدكتور محمد مرسي هو يحكم
الخوف من عوده النظام القديم يعني
الاندفاع في سكه اه اه تفضيل مرشح ما هذا
او ذاك يحكمه على الجانبين هي الخوف من
الطرف الاخر الخوف من المستقبل هؤلاء
يمثلون بالنسبه لكثير من المواطنين درجه
من درجات المخاوف على الجانب الاخر
الاخرون التحالف الاجتماعي الذي ناصر اه
كل بقايا النظام القديم وقبل
سواء لصالح السيد عمرو موسى او ال
ال ال الفريق احمد شفيق في الجوله الاولى
كان يحكم العنصر الرئيسي هو الخوف من
المستقبل من ان تتولى عناصر سوريه و اه
حكومه اه تغير من قواعد اللعبه وتغير من
قواعد المصالح التي اه اه ترسخ تعبر اكثر
من اربعين سنه داخل النظام السياسي
المؤسسه وكانت مصالح ماليه مصالح اه
سياسيه اه تحا لفتره
الرئيسي العنصر الثاني الحاكم في الموضوع
هو حاله من حالات الاضطراب السياسي ناتج
سواء من الاداره سيئه للمجلس العسكري في
المرحله الانتقاليه من ناحيه ومن ناحيه
اخرى حاله من حالات الاضطراب سببها في
معسكر الثوره اداء اه اه كان فيه درجه من
درجات الاستحواذ وعدم الرغبه في مشاركه
القوى الثوريه الاخرى من جانب الاخوان
المسؤولين هذا العنصر ايضا لعب دور في
الساحه السياسيه و ارباك الاختيارات لدى
قطاعات واسعه من المواطنين المصريين علينا
محمود اه عندما ننظر الى المشهد العام
انظروا في اطار سياق سياسي متكامل اه ظهور
السيد المستشار احمد الزند في حديث الناري
لم يكن مقطوع الصله بالاداء السيء للمرحله
الانتقاليه حكم المحكمه الدستوريه يشي
باتجاه ما داخل الدوله السفليه هذه الدوله
العميقه من اجل انتاج نظام سياسي على مقاس
مع محدد وبالتالي نحن بصدد صراع سياسي لم
يكتمل ملامحه بعد ولم يصل الى نهاياته حتى
الان دكتور مرج عبد الحميد ايا كانت
الاسباب والمبررات التي ساقها ضيوفنا هنا
بشان التراجع نسبه المشاركه من انتخابات
الى اخرى فان الحقيقه الثابته هي تراجع ان
نسبه المشاركه هل تخشى ان يعود المواطن
المصري البسيط مره اخرى الى استقالته من
السياسه التي سحبها عقب الثوره وشارك في
هذه الانتخابات
اه مساء الخير لا اعتقد هذا ولكن دعني
بدايه يعني مضيف الى ما قيل شيء جديد انه
اه الكتل التصويتيه من وجهه نظري يمكن
تقسيمها الى اربع كتل تصويتيه كتله
تصويتيه هي زي ما انت اشرت في كلمتك هي
كتله الدكتور محمد مرسي الكتله تريد
الاخوان المسلمين وتسعى ومش خوف ولا حاجه
محدده و كتله تصويتيه اخرى تريد الفريق
شفيق وهي محدده ايضا ولها مصالح مع الفريق
شفيق قتلى ثالثه وهي الكتله التي لا تريد
الدكتور موسى ولا تريد اه الفريق شفيق
ولكنها ربما تكون اميل مثلا بعضها اميل
الى فكره الدوله المدنيه وترى ان احتمال
ان يكون هو المدافع عن الدوله المدنيه
فنزلت يعني على مدى تصوت له وكتله اخرى مش
عايز الحلول لكنها ممكن ان تكون اميل الى
المزاج الاسلامي العام فنزل التصويت الى
اه موسى هناك الكتله الرابعه وهي الكتله
الرافضه لكلا المرشحين واللي محدده نفسها
ومحدده ما صار ها في انها تمتلك وسوف
تدافع وتتبنى المسار السوري رفضه بوضوح
الى المعسكرين رفضهم بوضوح مصره محدده
عندها رؤيه واضحه وهذه الرؤيه اعتقد انها
حب الورد نفسها في المرحله القادمه انا
اعتقد انه ال اربع كتل اللي حركت العمليه
الانتخابيه في جوله الاعاده اه بهذا
المعنى نعتقد ان التصويت بالتاكيد سوف يق
ل لانه الكتله الرابعه اللي هي الكتله
المقاطعه الرافضه ال غير مقتنعه ب كلا
المرشحين كتله في اعتقادي انها ليست
بالكتله ال اه القليله اضف الى هذا هناك
احد الاشياء الطريق لم ياتي اطلاقا طوال
اليومين الانتخابيين وهي مجموعه دقيقه
واحده وهي كتله
السلفيين قتله السلفيين في اعتقادي فيها
اعتقادي انها لم تتحرك التحرك الذي كان
منتظر منها بمعنى ان السلفيون الذي وعدوا
بانهم سوف يعطوا اصواتهم الى محمد مرسي في
اعتقادي انهم لم يتحركوا بالقدر الكافي
كان لو كان لهم المرشح المستقل بمعنى ان
جزء من هذه الكتله ربما يكون نزل فعلا
للمشاركه في العمليه الانتخابيه لصالح
مرسي او والبعض القليل منهم لصالح شفيق
لكن فيه كبير من كتله السلفيين
اصلا فيه هذه الجوله ونعتقد ان هذا ما
يؤثر بالفعل على نسبه التصويت هذه المره
واللي اعتقد كما تمت الاشاره لن تتجاوز
حدود الخمسه وثلاثين في المائه في هذه
الانتخابات
اذن السؤال المنطقه الذي يطرح نفسه في هذه
المرحله هو هل تؤثر نسبه المشاركين في
انتخابات الاعاده او في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه برمتها في قدره الرئيس القادم
على مواجهه التحديات التي تعين له
والقائمه بالفعل حاليا هذا السؤال نناقش
اجابته بعد فاصل قصير
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا من ما وراء
الخبر التي تتناول الدلالات انخفاض نسبه
المشاركه في جوله الاعاده من انتخابات
الرئاسه المصريه واثر ذلك على اه موقف
الرئيس المقبل من التحديات التي تواجهه
دكتور عمار اه اه
كثيرون يتحدثون عن ان الرئيس الجديد سيكون
منزوع الصلاحيات منزوع الدسم لا يستطيع ان
يمارس كل سلطاته حتى لو فاز الفريق احمد
شفيق الذي على ما يبدو هناك توافق بين من
مستوى مع المؤسسه العسكريه هل تؤيد هذا
الركن سواء جاء موسى او جاء شفيق فانه لن
يستطيع ان يكون كامل الصلاحيات لا يعول ان
هناك فرق بين الصلاحيات التي هندسها
القانون او الدستور وبين تلك الذي يستطيع
الشخص ان ينتزعها بمهاراته بحنكته وقدرتها
على تعبئه الراي العام ب بعد الاخلاق
بقدرات الكاريزميه ب اه اه اتفاق مساره
بتعاون مع القوى السياسيه الاخرى يستطيع
ان يعيشها ويع بها ان اراد لكن انا اعتقد
انه في حاله الدكتور موسى وفي حاله الفريق
احمد شفيق كلاهما الم يلجا الى هذه
المساله الدكتور موسى اذا قدر له النجاح
سيكون
صرف بالضروره سواء من قبيل الغريزه
الاخوانيه التاريخيه او نتيجه الظروف التي
وضع فيها ان يهدد علاقات ويبنيها على كسب
ثقه المجلس العسكري صاحب القوى الرئيسيه
الان اكثر منك ثقه الصور والشعب المصري
الفريق شفيق لا يحتاج على الاطلاق لان
علاقته اه مفتوحه بهذا لكن انا افترض لو
كان هناك اه اه شخص اخر غير هذين الشخصين
انا اتصور كانها يلجا الى تعبئه الراي
العام في مواجهه المؤسسه العسكريه ولا
يصبح المماحكات القانونيه او ما ينص عليه
القانون او الدستور موجود يستخدم في اه في
بعض الاوقات لكن ليس هو عنصر القوه
الرئيسيه في اداره الامور انما التفاعلات
على الارض وتوازنات القوه وشخصيه الرئيس
وقدرته على تعبئه الراي العام واه تبني
قضايا تحظى ب اجماع وطني واه علاقه
الدوليه والخبرات والمهارات الدبلوماسيه
كل هذه تلعب دورا بعيدا عن النصوص هذه
النصوص يلجا اليها حين يحتدم الخلاف او
يكون هناك اه طرف لديه رغبه في استخدامها
لكن النصوص
لتوضح في الاجراء الاضراب وتستخدم في
الوقت المناسب في تصفيه الحساب السياسي
الدكتور عبد الخالق ال ال اه المرشحين
الرئاسيين كلاهما اغلق الكثير من الوعود
خلال الحمله الانتخابيه وربما بعضهم لن
يكون او ربما كلاهما لن يكون قادرا على
الانجاز هذه الوعود بشخصه او بنفسه هل
تعتقد ان بناء تحالف اوسع للحكم في الفتره
القادمه من خلال تعيين رئيس وزراء مثلا او
تشكيل الامر بتشكيل حكومه هذا الحقل احد
الشخصيات الوطنيه ربما كان البرادعي ربما
اه اه احد ال ال بينافسوا في الجوله
الاولى من انتخابات الرئاسه بما يعني
المشاركه الاوسع في ممارسه السلطه هل
تعتقد ان هذا يساعد اكثر على الانجاز سواء
كان ذلك الفائز ال مرسي او شفيق صحيح لكن
الذهاب الى الامنيات بمعزل عن السياق اللي
قالوا فيه اداء كل طرف من هذين الطرفين
الحقيقه اه يضعنا في اه مجال اه اه غير
محسوب على الاطلاق نحن لدينا اه التحالفين
اجتماعيين قوتين سياسيتين لها جذورها
الاجتماعيه او لها تحالفاتها الاجتماعيه
ولها مدركاتها السياسيه اللي عبرت عن
نفسها في اداء على مدار الخمسه عشره شهرا
الاخيره لا الاخوان وده ال ال المحزن في
الامر ممكن يذهبوا الى هذا لانه كان من
الممكن انه تحسم معركه الان ال ال العاده
فورا لو لو كان الاخوان من اللحظه الاولى
قبلوا بفكره الشراكه الوطنيه مع بيد القوى
كان حسم المعركه
بفارق عده ملايين من الاصوات يصبح منتهى
لكنهم اصرارهم على الانسان وحدهم ب اه
مفاتيح ما وصلوا اليه الحقيقه اه يجعلنا
لا نستطيع ان نذهب الى مدى استشاري او
نتصور انه من الممكن ان يؤدوا اه هذا
الدور او يمارس هذه السياسه اذا ما
اه تمكن الدكتور محمد مرسي من الوصول الى
مقعد الياس بل على العكس حيبقى م حابب ما
يمكن تسميته فراغ القوه فراغ القوه ليست
هناك وراء ومؤسسات وبالتالي اللي
تعتقد ان الزلزال المتمثل في حل البرلمان
الذي كانوا يعولون عليه كثيرا كمؤسسه
دستوريه قويه لهم الاغلبيه الا تعتقد ان
هذا
على الاطلاق انه حتى اللحظات الاخيره نحن
لدينا في المائه ما اطلقنا عليه النداء
الاخير وذهب وافده من
مباشره وذهبوا وجلسوا في حوار مكثف مع
قياده الاخوان المسلمين ومكتب الارشاد حتى
فجر يوم الجمعه ومع ذلك لن تتزحزح لحظه
واحده او موسى واحده عن موقفهم السابق
ولديهم اه يقين بان النصر قادم و ان
التقارير الحقيقه اداء يعكس درجه من درجات
الايمان الجيني اكثر من
السياسي على الجانب الاخر اه الفريق شفيق
لا يستطيع ان يتحرك بعيدا عن قوه رئيسيه
القوى التي دفعت الاله التنظيميه للحزب
الوطني وكل جماعات المصالح القديمه من
رجال المال والاعمال اللي هما مو لو هذه
الحمله قوي جدا
مثلا لابد ان ولابد ان ياتي بهم لانه هو
لازم يتعلم ارجاء البحث القوى الاخرى
المؤثره وهو المجلس العسكري سوف يكون في
كلا الحالتين هو اداه من ادوات اه هاتين
القوتين من اجل تنفيذ سياسات سواء في
الداخل او في تحالفاتها الاقليميه
والدوليه اه اه الحاله المصريه الحقيقه اه
بعد جوله الاعاده حاله شديده الخطر شديده
القلق اه لا تبشر للاسف الشديد باستقرار
اوضاع على مدى الشهور القليله القادمه قد
يتحرك هذا الرئيس الجديد في اطار اجراء
بعض الاصلاحات الجزئيه لكن بحكم نمط ادائه
من هذا الجانب او التحالفات ومدركات
السياسيه غير قادره على تلبيه مصالح
طموحات المصريين اللي اندلعت
اكثر صبرا وابعد نظرا
نطرح السؤال
السؤال
انا اقول اقول المواطن يعني المصري
المتفائل وال مفرط في التفاؤل
لانتخابات الرئاسه ستكون الترياق الشكل كل
المشكلات التي تمر بها في هذه المرحله
دعني اطرح سؤال الدكتور مجدى عبد الحميد
دكتور مجدي ال ال ال النفط التحول المصري
الديمقراطي او تتحول السياسي الذي شهدته
مصر بعد الثوره ما صار مطرب للغايه مسار
متعثر وجاءت ه العديد من التحديات ولا
ينتظر ان تزول هذه التحديات بمجرد وصول
الرئيس القادم هل مرسي او شفيق كلاهما
يستطيع ان يصل بمصر الى الامل المنشود في
دوله ديمقراطيه مدنيه اه اه على النفط ال
ال الذي اه هي عليه الدول المحترمه في
الخارج
اه اعتقادي ان كلا المرشحين وهذا هو السبب
الحقيقي في انه هناك رفض
واسع من قطاعات كبيره من الشعب المصري
وخاصه ممن تبنوا شعارات الثوره ان كلا
المرشحين يعبر عن برنامج اقتصادي واحد
وهذا ما لم يختلف من واحد حتى الان
برنامجهم الاقتصادي هو نفس البرلمان
الاقتصادي للنظام القديم لم يحدثنا اه
الفريق برنامج اقتصادي غير رغم انه حدثنا
عن مجموعه من الوعود وفكره الوعود
الانتخابيه كلنا نعلم ان في الانتخابات
تاتي عشرات ومئات والاف الوعود وخاصه فيما
يتعلق بال مكتسبات ال اه الاجتماعيه اما
على الجانب الاخر اه
الدكتور موسى ايضا لم يحدثنا عن برنامج
اقتصادي جديد الى المرشحين يتبنى نفس
البرنامج الاقتصادي الذي اودى
بالاوضاع الاقتصاديه المصريه والاجتماعيه
طوال السنوات العشره والعشرين الماضيه اي
انهم يتبنوا نفس البرنامج الذي يدعو الى
تحرير الصحف اه اه السوق نفس البرنامج
الذي يدعو الى الخصخصه نفس البرنامج الذي
يدعو الى تثبيث العلاقات
الاقتصاديه الدوليه القائمه حاليا
اه نعم انا عايزه اقول من رؤيه تنمويه من
ايا من المرشحين المغايره للرؤيه التنمويه
التي كانت مطروحه من قبل وبناء عليه ما
الذي يمكن ان يقدمه للشعب المصري لانه في
النهايه حتى على مستوى امكانيات التحولات
الديمقراطيه الحقيقيه نمره واحد لابد ان
يكون لدى ايام الى المرشحين او ايام ما
اردت اقل لابد ان يكون لديه قناه حقيقيه
بالقيم والمبادئ الديمقراطيه والحريه
والعداله لا اعتقد ان كلا المرشحين يتبنى
هذه الرؤيه 12 الان حيث اني احد يقول
الدكتور مش بيدعي انه جزء من قوه الصوره
ولكن تعالوا نشوف اداء حزب الحريه
والعداله في البرلمان في الفتره اللي فاتت
هناك قانون يا سيدي يدعو الى تحرير دكتور
بالمشاركه المجتمعيه يبقى المزيد من الوقت
الدكتور مدعي عذرا على المقاطعه اشكر كذلك
ضيفي الدكتور عمار على حسن الباحث والكاتب
السياسي والدكتور عبد الخالق فاروق مدير
مركز النيل للدراسات الاستراتيجيه واشكرك
مشاهدينا الاعزاء على حسن المتابعه لكم من
التحيه والى اللقاء
ام